Stellt euch vor ihr seid krank und euer Schmerzmittel,
euer Antidepressivum oder sogar euer Krebsmittel
ist über Wochen oder sogar Monate einfach ausverkauft.
Das Ganze ist kein abstraktes Problem mehr, sondern Alltag in vielen Apotheken.
Und das nicht irgendwo auf der Welt, sondern hier in Deutschland.
Habt ihr das vielleicht selber schon mal erlebt?
Hier oben könnt ihr an einer kleinen Umfrage dazu teilnehmen
oder ihr schreibt es uns in die Kommentare.
Es würde uns auf jeden Fall interessieren.
Wir wollen in dieser Folge zoomIN auf jeden Fall mal darauf gucken,
wie groß das Problem überhaupt ist, was die Ursachen dafür sind.
Und ob, und wenn ja wie, die Ausbreitung des Coronavirus
dazu führen könnte, dass es sogar noch schlimmer wird.
Wir wollten heute eigentlich ein ganz normales Erklärvideo machen
zu den Medikamentenengpässen in Deutschland.
Und darüber, dass es immer mehr Medikamente gibt,
die irgendwie nicht lieferbar sind, das hat unterschiedlichste Gründe.
Aber das war heute Morgen noch ganz weit weg. Und dann ist das hier passiert.
Na, wie ist die Lage? – Joa, ganz gut.  Mein Kollege Chris macht gerade nämlich genau die Erfahrung,
über die wir hier heute sprechen wollen.
Und deswegen ist das Problem irgendwie gar nicht mehr so weit weg
und nur für einen Erklärfilm, sondern hier im Büro und deswegen
rufen wir den einfach mal an und fragen mal, was da los war.
Heute Morgen war die Visite da und die haben mir mitgeteilt,
dass das eine Antibiotikum gerade wegen Lieferengpässen nicht verfügbar ist.
Deswegen wurde es jetzt auf ein anderes Antibiotikum umgestellt.
Und war das für die ein ganz normales Alltagsprozedere
oder haben die irgendwie gesagt „ja, es tut uns super Leid,
das verändert jetzt irgendwas in der Medikation oder hieß es einfach nur
„joa, das ist jetzt halt ein anderes Produkt?“
Ne, das war eher so ne Randnotiz.
Wie bei Chris schaffen es die Apotheken im Krankenhaus oder in der Stadt
in den meisten Fällen einen Ersatz zu finden. Aber das klappt nicht immer
und das Problem wächst. Immer häufiger fehlen Medikamente
oder sogar die Wirkstoffe. Und da fast alles in Asien hergestellt werden,
könnte das Problem durch das Coronavirus sogar noch schlimmer werden.
Aktuell sind in Deutschland lauf offizieller Liste
circa 270 Arzneimittel nicht lieferbar. Insgesamt zugelassen
sind in Deutschland aber 103.000 Medikamente für Menschen.
Das heißt, es ist weniger als 1%.  ABER: Je nach dem,
wie sehr ein Mensch darauf angewiesen ist, reicht genau
dieses eine Medikament oder dieses eine Prozent, das fehlt.
Und es geht dabei nicht nur um bestimmte Mittel,
sondern um ganz unterschiedliche. Das fängt mit der normalen Ibuprofen an,
geht über Antidepressiva, Blutdruckmittel bis hin zu Krebsmedikamenten.
Und wenn dann ein Medikament fehlt, müssen die Therapien unterbrochen,
verschoben oder sogar komplett umgestellt werden.
Nur, weil das Medikament gerade nicht verfügbar ist.
Laut Apothekenverband haben sich die Lieferengpässe jedes Jahr seit 2017 verdoppelt.
2019 waren 18 Millionen Packungen Rabattarzneimittel nicht lieferbar.
Ein Lieferengpass ist natürlich nicht gleich ein Versorgungsnotstand.
Das heißt in den meisten Fällen kann man ausweichen. Aber das geht eben nicht immer.
Und all das hat bisher rein gar nichts mit dem Coronavirus zu tun
und es ist auch nichts Neues. Warnungen von Experten gibt es schon seit über 10 Jahren.
Dass die Ausfälle seit Jahren zunehmen, hat unterschiedliche Gründe.
Aber einer der Hauptgründe ist, dass in Europa fast keine Wirkstoffe
mehr produziert werden. 80 % der Wirkstoffe kommen aus Billiglohnländern in Asien,
die meisten aus China und Indien. Und da vor Ort dann meistens
auch noch aus wenigen Fabriken. Das heißt, wenn einer der Produzenten ausfällt,
weil irgendetwas verunreinigt war oder die Produktion ins Stocken gerät,
hat das Auswirkungen auf die ganze Welt.
Das macht die Medikamente zum einen bei uns besonders günstig,
zum anderen macht es uns aber auch besonders abhängig.
Sehr sarkastisch formuliert, sage ich gerne:
die Chinesen brauchen gar keine Atombombe.
Sie liefern einfach keine Antibiotika. Und dann erledigt sich Europa.
Man muss ein bisschen warten, eine Atombombe geht schneller,
aber dann erledigt sich Europa von alleine.
Das klingt extrem, aber tatsächlich gibt es in Deutschland
keinen Hersteller für Antibiotika mehr. Der letzte hat 2017 dicht gemacht.
Die Unternehmen sagen, für sie lohnt es sich kaum in Europa zu produzieren,
weil der Kostendruck so hoch sei. Wie sind wir jetzt in diese Abhängigkeit geraten?
Ja, das ist die Frage nach Henne und Ein, nicht? Was ist denn zuerst da gewesen?
Der Kostendruck? Und dann ist man nach China und Indien gegangen,
um preiswerter oder, man kann es auch einfach sagen,
billiger produzieren zu können. Aber es ist natürlich auch so,
die Pharmafirmen wollen natürlich auch ihren Gewinn optimieren,
und das läuft miteinander parallel.
Als ein Grund für den Kostendruck bei den Unternehmen nennen Experten
immer wieder das sogenannte Rabattsystem. Das heißt,
dass Krankenkassen Rabattverträge mit bestimmten Herstellern abschließen.
Und sie sagen damit, wir nehmen euch dieses Medikament ab und sorgen dafür,
dass unsere Versicherten dieses Medikament verschrieben bekommen.
Das macht es zwar für Krankenkassen und Patienten billiger,
erhöht aber den Druck auf die Pharmakonzerne.
Die Krankenversicherer in Deutschland entscheiden aufgrund
eines einzigen Kriteriums. Das ist der Preis. Das heißt,
die Krankenversicherer entscheiden sich nicht für den Anbieter
mit dem besten Preis-Leistungsverhältnis, sondern sie nehmen
nur den billigsten Anbieter.
Das bedeutet auch, dass dann die Hersteller, die keinen Rabattvertag abschließen,
ihre Produktion entweder drosseln oder ganz einstellen.
Wenn der Hauptproduzent mit dem Rabattvertrag ein Lieferproblem hat,
bricht die ganze Kette zusammen. Denn so schnell können andere Unternehmen
ihre Produktion nicht wieder nach oben fahren.
Das bringt uns zur Frage:
Welche Auswirkungen hat jetzt das Coronavirus auf die Versorgung?
Und diese Frage lässt sich gar nicht so ohne Weiteres seriös beantworten,
denn die Situation ändert sich sowohl in den produzierenden Ländern
als auch hier vor Ort täglich oder sogar stündlich.
Aktuell kommen in Indien sogar schon weniger Wirkstoffe aus China an
und das Land hat deswegen angekündigt, den Export
von einigen Mitteln einzuschränken. Das heißt es kann also sein,
dass es durchaus zu weiteren Engpässen kommt.
Trotzdem besteht wohl kein Grund zu Panik.
Die zuständige Behörde betont, dass es aktuell keine konkreten Hinweise darauf gibt,
dass sich die Engpässe durch Corona verschärfen.
Und das gilt wohl mindestens bis in den Herbst. Auch die meisten Hersteller betonen,
sie seien gut gewappnet. Was aber auch klar ist:
Wenn die Produktion in Indien oder in China gedrosselt wird – und sei das nur,
weil die Angestellten krank sind – und der weltweite Güterverkehr eingeschränkt wird,
entweder von den Staaten oder auch da einfach, weil die Menschen krank sind,
dann könnte das fatale Folgen haben.
Wenn dort wie jetzt aufgrund des Corona-Virus die Lieferwege gestört sind,
kann es sein, dass in drei bis sechs Monaten die ersten Patientinnen und
Patienten keine Antibiotika mehr bekommen. Mit den entsprechenden Konsequenzen,
was im schlimmsten Fall zu Todesfällen führen kann.
Die Politik ist spätestens jetzt alarmiert und fordert mehr Medikamente "Made in Europe".
Aber sie kann den Unternehmen natürlich nicht vorschreiben,
wo sie ihre Wirkstoffe einkaufen und wo sie zu produzieren haben.
Und eine Rückverlagerung wird ohne finanzielle Anreize oder bestimmte Sicherheiten
für die Unternehmen höchstwahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Auch die Pharmakonzerne und die Apotheker haben natürlich diverse Forderungen,
was sich am System ändern sollte. Beide fordern allerdings eine Veränderung
des Rabattsystems. Sie wollen gesetzlich verpflichtend bewirken, dass mehr
als ein Hersteller bei den Rabattverträgen von den Krankenversicherungen zum Zuge kommt.
Bisher schieben sich Pharmakonzerne, Politik, Krankenkassen und Apotheken
gerne gegenseitig die Schuld zu. Für eine wirkliche Veränderung
brauchen wir viel Zeit und Geld.
Und das Problem war vor Corona schon groß und könnte jetzt
vermutlich noch größer werden. Wenn ihr auf bestimmte Medikamente angewiesen seid,
fragt am besten mal bei eurem Arzt nach.
Hier oben findet ihr noch ein Video mit mehr Informationen zum Coronavirus
und hier unten unsere Playlist. Und nicht vergessen – abonnieren.